well in the last few minutes housing
communities and local government
secretary
robert generic has spoken let's have a
listen well
the public health situation in greater
manchester
continues to deteriorate we've now had
10 days
of discussions in good faith with local
leaders in greater manchester
we've not so far been able to reach an
agreement
we've offered a comprehensive package of
support
in addition to the national measures
that have been set out
by the chancellor i've written this
evening
to the mayor of greater manchester and
to local leaders
in the city region to say that if we're
not able
to reach agreement by noon tomorrow
then with deep regret i'll have to
advise the prime minister
that we're not able to reach an
agreement at this time
we're live to our deputy political
editor sam coats who's in manchester
and sam talks over tier three
restrictions for manchester have been
deadlocked for days but it seems tonight
that the government has run out of
patience
that's right after eight days of
standoff between the greater manchester
politicians
and westminster tonight downing street
and the community secretary have set a
deadline of midday tomorrow
and if an agreement cannot be struck
between the two sides by then
then boris johnson will impose tier
three restrictions
automatically closing down bars and
restaurants in this region
without any further discussion any
further compensation package
this comes after a day of torturous
discussions
that founded this afternoon on the fact
that a hardship package that many of the
10 local authority leaders from the
greater manchester area and andy burnham
had been expecting
uh to be on the table uh from central
government uh
later downing street uh said that
discussions weren't progressing
and said they were considering their
options then tonight about an hour ago
andy burnham and richard lisa mayor of
manchester city
released a statement going as far as
questioning whether or not central
government
were fiddling the figures and
exaggerating the case on how many people
are in intensive care
an incredible accusation to uh to make
they said in the
statement that the government sought to
raise public concern about the nhs
in greater manchester with selective
statistics
now in the last 10 minutes uh the
government have given their response in
the form of a statement that you just
heard from robert generick
he says that while talks aren't over
they've got a matter of hours
for both sides to come to an agreement
if not there will be no deal
and the government will impose its will